مشاهدينا قبل ان نفتح ملفات الحصاد نتابع
التطوراتي في العراق حيث قالت وزاره
الداخليه ان ما لا يقل عن 10 اشخاص هم في
عداد المفقودين داخل المبنى الذي تعرض
لحريق في الوزيريه في وسط بغداد من جهتها
اعلنت مديريه الدفاع المدني عن اصابه نحو
20 من عناصرها في انهيار البنايه المكونه
من ثلاثه طوابق والتي التهمتها النيران
ونقلت وكاله الانباء العراقيه عن مصادر في
الدفاع المدني قولها انا نحو 50 فرقه من
فرق الدفاع المدني تشارك في عمليات اطفاء
الحريق المتوسط والذي تسبب في اضرار كبيره
في البنايات المجاوره وعدد من السيارات
القريبه من موقع الحريق
لمزيد من التفاصيل معنى من بغداد مدير
مكتب الجزيره وليد ابراهيم وليد ما الذي
جرى بالتحديد
الساعه الثانيه عشر ظهرا بحسب التوقيت
المحلي لمدينه بغداد اي قبله 11 ساعه
بالضبط كان هناك حريقه اندلع في احد
المخازن قالت مصادر الدفاع المدني انه
مخزن ل- همم للمواد للعطور والمواد التي
تستخدم في العطور ال- ال- الحريق
ليصل الى محلات اخرى مجاوره والى بنايات
اخرى عديده مجاوره وانا اتحدث حسن اترك
الكاميرا ايضا تنقل ما يجري
الحريق الذي اندلع في المخزن امتد بشكل
سريع جدا الى البنايات القريبه من المخزن
وهذا صعب كثيرا على رجال الدفاع المدني
الذين يتواجدون حتى في هذه اللحظه باعداد
كبيره جدا صعب عليهم محمد او مهمه السيطره
على هذا الحريق هذا المخزن وفي هذه المكان
الذي نتواجد نحن فيه هي منطقه تسمى منطقه
الوزيريه او تحديدا الحي الصناعي في
الوزيريه هو عباره عن مقر لشركات ومصانع
ومخازن همم للعديد من الشركات المحليه
العامله في العراق
جزء من هذه المخازن ايضا يضم مواد همم
للاشتعال وهذا هو الذي ساعد في او الذي
سهل عمليات انتشار النيران في مكان واسع
هذا بالتحديد هذه الصور حسن هي بالتحديد
المخزن الذي وقع فيه الحريق اول الامر
ليمتد الى المناطق الاخرى همم حسب همم
العديد من العائلات ما زالت تنتظر هنا اي
حديث عن ذويها الذين الذين ما زالوا
مفقودين لا احد يعرفهم على وجه الدقه قبل
قليل تحدث مدير العلاقات في وزاره
الداخليه اللواء سعد ما قال ان عدد
المفقودين بحدود ثلاثه عشر شخصا همم
العوائل تتحدث عن اكثر من هذا الرقم على
ايه حال
فرق الدفاع المدني تمكنت من السيطره على
الحريق على الاقل حتى الان لا نعرف اذا
كان سيده يلعب مره اخرى ام لا لان تحدثت
قبل قليل مع ال- مع الناس الذين يتواجدون
هنا قالوا انه في اكثر من مره يتم سيطره
على الحريق وتندلع مره اخرى السنه النار
تشتعل وهذا يعني ان هناك مواد
داخل المخزن ما زالت ما زالت حتى اللحظه
قد تكون قد تشتعل مره اخرى على ايه حال
همم الوضع الان قد يكون تم السيطره عليه
من فرق الدفاع المدني لكن بكل تاكيد
الحديث الان هو ينصب باتجاه عدد الضحايا
كم هو عدد ضحايا الذين سقطوا في هذا
الحادث حتى هذه اللحظه نعم حسن وليد
ابراهيم مدير مكتب الجزيره من بغداد شكرا
جزيلا لك